[Music]  Camila Cabello has no regrets the 20  year old singer opens up about her  decision to leave fifth harmony to focus  on her solo career in a new interview  with the edits January issue quote I  began writing songs and I didn't want to  give them away to anybody else because  they were about me I was finding my  voice  the musical fivesome placed in third on  The X Factor in 2012  [Music]  and the Havana songstress says her time  with the group pushed her to be better  quote it shaped me entirely I feel like  being part of a group teaches you so  many things about yourself ironically  and it also brings out this healthy  competition Kibeho left the group in  December 2016 and the remaining members  told ET in July 2017 we are doing so not  about where the happiest we've ever been  and so many exciting things are  happening for us right now so we're  doing credible  [Music]